welcome to this video cyber smooth sloth
ya don't know that guy okay let's try
the same Michigan somehow recently I
mean play some other classical recently
and not so much of this opening and when
I did it didn't didn't really turn out
to be so great it's a question of a
little bit of a question of the opening
anyway but don't really know why why I
get to get into problems here recently
is six does it have c5 plate
hmm yeah it's it's normally I thought
you had that you do lose some material
here but you always have some kind of
compensation I mean always is a bit
strong but very often let's see how Adam
unfolds in this game one issue that
black hairs is the somewhat awkward
position here on the King side with the
night here on the aid it is some very
often allowing some some attacking
possibilities okay so he's just putting
it on d6 what do I want to play I mean
okay it's clear what I want to do I want
to play Queen age three and sort of go
go a tech age seven queen is a bit wrong
on d3 here and he has got night b3 this
is also some somehow in the in the
position I'd like to play a bishop a
b.a.d to rookie one but he's got night
be three
hmm don't know that doesn't look too hot
it's got Queenie 74 Queenie for ok I
have to play one of those moves he can
go when I be three though and just take
you to and I would have done that I
think i'm not sure if this and i'm not
saying that this is a mistake but I just
say that it wouldn't have been my choice
ok I have this funny Nigeria but it's
not leading to to that much at the
moment I can't like it play it I mean I
can play this move but he's got rookie
aid and I'm not sure I'm threatening
anything so what what does this all mean
I have to somehow get the look into the
game look Rick somewhere okay now I can
put it put it on age three I can maybe
take d2 and take a five right okay I
don't have much choice
yeah there's 96 business and this is
always somehow in the position going to
do that mostly because of the caption 94
very very strange kind of position it
doesn't look like it should be okay for
me but it's always always tricky I hear
he has the d5 square sometimes in some
lines if we imagine I take on g7 now for
check on age 32 rook h7 King g7 Queen as
you check King back 96 queen age eight
major threat but he has Queen to d5 and
this saves the day if somehow this is
not existing then this is a very serious
idea 96 first is also a serious idea if
it takes it pawn takes 25 this rook h8
business is working in fact it is
working yes hmm then it's interesting
but of 96 he can always play night x f
five maybe rook f pawn takes and black
holes okay so he is afraid of it he's
definitely afraid her pain of the
sacrifice so should I play 96 and then
take there or I'm going to play it maybe
a wee night h5 also might be an idea
yeah I can take now or
came on there's no all I have to do it
yeah this is why you play the same ish
it's kind of it's it's it's really
caveman style but it is dangerous h4
maybe rookie 30 hours may be coming so
Queen g34 queen age for not quite sure
if this is threatening anything though
and ya still on rookie three years a
problem it's not working chikis is
completely useless ok I'm going to do it
I have to get in your skin snow no way
around that and there are ideas like 95
and so on it's not so like I'm not
having any ideas still rookie 3 m's may
be possible I didn't think about that
one but what he's doing is he just says
that Queen age 4 is not a threat that
this is not threatening anything which
is maybe true hmm ok
and linework f4 looks decidedly wrong
age 49 f 1 is not working okay let's
just do that I really don't know if it
is leading to anything neither one I go
95 this I didn't expect for what exactly
Knight f3 neither three years son Wow ok
so I have to move this probably
hmm I still don't threaten 95 thats it's
bad really that I'm not still not
threatening anything
at least now I threaten you cage 8 and
95 double check he's just threw just
allowing it check can you believe any of
that no mouse lip nah what did you take
I mean not that this is great ematic ask
them mouse lapeer ok come on White Rose
I and yeah great Queen age 6 of course
teenage six now I wanted to take and
give the check I mean I don't know what
this is but I have to play it yeah it's
just coincidental when it's even good
for white threatening me this year this
is really a coincidence or this given by
the comp but I didn't see any of that
beforehand I have a city mouse slip yeah
probably this is not working but this is
it hmm it's very tricky and really is
really protecting everything here it
looks dangerous but it's somehow holding
here 93 i was i was expecting this move
but this is not check not as good
hmm nobody knows what's going on in this
position yeah maybe I should go 95 now
when i when i played this I of course I
didn't see this move I was always
thinking I have this but of course he
has this real I with the meteor I made
on g2 the only side now then I had to
play this is silly move and she I am ok
it's better to Jack to this and the
check now ok where's his office is
really crazy but hear it again Josh
check the Jeep on runs Wow yeah nobody
knows what's going on there yeah he
defended defended this is very well it
was a very dif this is a very dangerous
attack this Bishop age 6 business it's
an interesting question if if here maybe
there's something better yeah there is
something better maybe our computers
undecided maybe with g3 is stronger all
night eh fire night h5 this was in fact
aha yeah I had this hunch that this
might be stronger these this kind of
attacks I mean those nights they are not
really helping that much so it's clear
that I have some attack but it's it's
very difficult to say this is something
sufficient more than sufficient equal or
whatever I don't know yeah I played it
well thanks for watching